any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
uh i'm going to ask you on the back back
to that hawking book because i'm not
seeing it hawking
hockey and very clever title uh i've
always wondered
is he really a world class one of the
top ever
physicist theoretical physicist whatever
um
or does his condition and his heroic
uh you know continuation of his work in
life despite
these incredible conditions against him
kind of elevate
him into almost a godlike status i i
used to see him every couple years he'd
come to caltech and give
a public talk you know it was quite a
show when he would show up at caltech
you know it'd be like well stephen is
speaking next wednesday night at
7. all right well like at two in the
afternoon there's people lined up
you know out in the lawn playing frisbee
and waiting you know for their free spot
in the
in the 1100 seat auditorium it's like
wow and then you know he rolls down the
aisle with his helpers in his chair
standing ovation just for showing up
before he even speaks and
you know people are just hanging on
every sentence and of course i get it
because you know his condition
his heroism and so on but i always
wondered you know is he you know
way up there in the pantheon of the
greatest of all time you know
newton einstein feynman hawking or not i
i just really have no way to judge that
no no that's a big thesis of this book
it sounds like you'd really enjoy it but
um the book
actually goes through as a physics his f
it goes in reverse from starting with
like
you know the movie about his life and
maybe his final papers
all the way back to his 1965 thesis with
dennis shiyama at uh at cambridge
at oxford i think he was at oxford and
um then he was teaching at cambridge
um but no it makes the case and actually
michael as you're right you know he
would come to america
he didn't get there on you know british
airways i mean he got there
on a private jet and oftentimes the
private jet was so
um was so even not inadequate he had to
take an ambulance jet
from cambridge to caltech uh that's not
inexpensive
so he had all these backers there's a
guy who backed him who had established a
stephen hawking
chair at texas a m and and he would have
him come out
and then once he was working on his
final papers with with like andy
strominger
and others and every time he'd get
approval from his doctor
to come out on the ambulance private jet
which is much more expensive than a
regular private jet
because there's only like one or two in
the world that could actually do it
uh and so andy straubinger talks about
how
they had to get him out and the doctor
said no he had gotten
really sick he had just had a flu i
think this is like 2016
2017 about a year before he died and
he's the doctor said no he's too ill to
travel
and then in the book uh it says that
his colleagues wrote to his doctor and
said if you don't let him come
it may cost a nobel prize and i thought
it was like it was perfect for my book
losing a nobel prize
is all about how scientists worship the
nobel prize as a kind of gilded graven
image
that literally has alfred nobel's
picture on it and we have as much of a
religious proclivity as any secular
you know humanist does except we think
it's all great because it's just
wrapped up on this fun thing called the
nobel prize but it was funny to me that
his doctor only let him go
at great risk to his own personal health
and maybe even the guy's
medical license uh by because of the
potential to win a nobel prize when
actually there was no chance of him
winning a nobel prize he did a lot of
good work what what
kind of hampered him um as this guy
talked about so for a while i was kind
of
um frustrated by hawking because i heard
him speak
several i heard him speak only once in
my life and that was in the 90s in in
london at a royal academy meeting
and he gave a public lecture and at the
end someone said why did you write a
brief history of time
it's rumored that no one's ever gotten
all the way through it not even you and
nobody understands it
and in his computerized voice i remember
this distinctly michael
he said because i had to pay for my
daughter's college
and everybody laughed it's kind of a
cute line but only now do i realize how
much he had to go through and leonard
milano's book that you had the biography
of friendship
i had leonard on my show and i realized
he had a form kind of stephen hawking
incorporated as i call it or hawking
hawking as
as seif calls it because he had to be
turned over imagine being turned over
every hour when you're sleeping to drain
your tracheostomy
and have fluid and like you couldn't why
you couldn't do anything you never had
privacy you had
your spouse was like your m your mother
or your parent like wiping it uh it's
disgusting i can't imagine how much
respect i have from on one hand
but it's impossible not to think that
that didn't play into this you know he
like literally he i interviewed neil
degrasse tyson the other day
and he said even during covid i couldn't
go down the street with a mask on and
not get recognized and that's like one
of
uh neil degrasse tyson's you know
biggest kind of frustration is just like
he has no privacy anymore
well stephen hawking said i can't like
put you know put cloaking devices on my
wheelchair like everyone's gonna know
who he was
everyone always wanted his time and so i
don't begrudge him for doing a lot of
things for financial reasons
um because he had he had to take care of
it just like galileo he had
ex-wives and children you know from
different people to support
um and there was this constant need that
and terror who else was going to provide
for him you know
one of the thesis of this book is that
he's not in the pantheon of the great
physicist
no it's definitely not no he's he's as i
said you know the two biggest things
that he claims
are his uh reasons to not believe in god
the
hawking heartless theorem and um and the
m theory that he
didn't contribute to but popularized
those are not accepted by the
lion's share of practicing physicist the
work he did on singularities is very
important but then again he kind of
disavowed that
to work on the no boundary theorem which
kind of obviates the need for a
singularity
and then the black hole hawking
radiation is incredibly interesting
fascinating mathematical work
that suggests that you know black holes
may emit
light with an equivalent temperature of
one trillionth the temperature of the
sun that will never be observed
um so for those reasons you might make
an argument that
that penrose you know did this great
work on black holes with stephen
and uh and so since penrose won the
nobel prize maybe hawking would have
but um but penrose made a numerous
amount of contributions
uh far beyond just the black holes for
which he was recognized
hawking was much more narrowly focused
and i think um
i think you know it's it's impossible to
imagine how much he how much he did
you know with so little physical ability
starting in the 19
early 1980s but certainly it was his it
was his his esteem amongst the general
public
is far eclipsing of his contributions to
most practicing like the amount of
citations that he has
to papers that he's done are very
limited in the practicing work of
physicists today
interesting let me ask this next
question by prefacing it with a quote
from darwin
when the origin species came out of
course there was
such some hullabaloo about its
implications for theism and
and the need for a designer to explain
life and so on
and uh so in the second edition he
addressed this question or
you know is the theory of evolution by
means of natural selection
a threat to belief in god and recall
that darwin's wife
emma was deeply religious and he
consciously avoided
uh being too militant about his eventual
agnosticism he never called himself an
atheist but here's what he wrote
about his own theory i see no good
reason why the views given in this
volume
should shock the religious feeling of
anyone it is satisfactory
as showing how transient such
impressions are to remember
that the greatest discovery ever made by
man namely the law of attraction of
gravity
was also attacked by leibniz as quote
subversive of natural and inferentially
of revealed religion
close quote from leibniz darwin
continues as celebrated author and
divine has written to me that he has
gradually learned to see that it is just
as noble a conception of the deity
to believe that he created a few
original forms
capable of self-development into other
needful forms
as to believe he required a fresh act of
creation to supply the voids
caused by the actions of his laws
so my question is is it possible that
there is a mind a conscious being a god
intelligent designer behind it all
and he does and the way he created
the universe stars planets life complex
organisms all the way up to us
and sentience is these laws of nature
that scientists are discovering that's
how he did it he did it through these
particular
laws gravity natural selection and so on
and therefore there's you're kind of
taking out of the equation this sort of
personal
god that well you can still believe in
that but separately from that
this is how he did it so in a way back
to the old natural theology arguments of
the
18th and 19th century studying nature is
a way of getting
at understanding god's mind because
those are the laws we're discovering
that's how god does it
um yeah i think that's a fantastic point
and on and one
not too dissimilar to the point i've
tried to raise to meijer
which is this um this notion of of um
of kind of uh lethargy or slothishness
of the deity so assume the deity existed
he instantiated the laws of the universe
he even programmed in that you know
carbon could form
in the heart of certain types of stars
from a triple alpha
nucleus collision that lasts for a
trillionth of a second under these exact
chemicals are and that would create
carbon
and then phosphorus would come later and
then gla you know gcta would you know
they'd all
precipitate out in different forms and
it would all part of this god's
plan um still it would have to be that
the deity instantiates that at very
early times
because there's no there's no censor
there's no interaction there's no
on a on a continual basis i don't think
people
uh believe that god is in there
separating you know rna
and and matching up uh pairs of dna
strands etcetera etcetera
so it is kind of the clockwork what's
that yeah
right so so therefore
the god that stephen believes in i said
to him
the inescapable conclusion is a deist
god
it's not a personal god uh in other
words it was a god that established the
laws that you and i would evolve and so
god created though let's just say i
stipulate that i believe there was an
intelligence let's say i do
he would have had to do so at an
extremely early time billions of years
before
homo sapiens would exist and then the
form of jesus christ would come 2000
years ago
so if if that is true then um then
god established the laws of nature that
by which we are to
grasp his interactions with humanity uh
extremely long ago so how is that
different than the deistic god
the unmoved mover or the you know the
first cause god
to me it doesn't display any difference
functionally um but
but you know so then yes so i think it's
a very different thing
and i asked him can you get not can you
get you know um
uh ought from is but can you get you
know
uh jesus or whatever or most god of
moses and abraham
can you get that from you know from is
in other words the fact that
the universe obeys laws of physics the
laws of biology and biochemistry and
eventually sociology and political
science and everything
can you get those laws um can you get a
personal god
from those laws i don't personally see
how you can
but uh that doesn't prevent me from
looking see here's the thing i i have
trouble with
agnosticism even myself i don't believe
that there's such thing as like a happy
super happy militant atheist
like there's just because you express
your opinion really forcefully
doesn't make it any more so than my
opinion as a happy buddhist you know
whatever right it's just like okay
that's just your form of expression
you yelling at me you know the god
doesn't exist doesn't help convince me
any more than a quiet reasoned argument
would have us
um so you know i like to think about you
know
what is the where can science where
would god display
his existence if he would and then what
would that
consequence so we all talk about like oh
that we we'd settle for
what woody allen called the divine
sneeze that's all i want a divine sneeze
and i hear that a lot from my atheist
friends they'll say you know
actually um i was reading a book
recently
um by avi loeb who you know and
um and you had on the show right
you had avion right yeah so he said oh
well you know if god
really didn't want abraham to kill
sacrifice
isaac he wrote this in the pages of that
trash pile of a magazine called
scientific america now i'm just mad that
you're not writing for them anymore
uh but anyway he wrote this in
scientific america i love avi but um
but he said you know all god needed to
do is give him like a modern-day iphone
and he could have recorded
it and i said avi come on you're a jew
you're an israeli
you're jewish like me did you not forget
the story of the golden calf
he's like no of course i know that you
know every israeli no matter how secular
they are michael
knows the bible the old testament better
than any sunday school preacher of
highest intensity that you'll ever meet
because they like get it in their public
schools they learn the torah
but anyway i said 40 days imagine this
40 days after witnessing 10 supernatural
plagues
devastate egypt the most powerful super
power country ever existed in human
history at that point
and then split the sea another miracle
and do all the
40 days after that they melt down some
gold and make an idol
and these are supposed to be jews i said
abby we're supposed to be kind of smart
you know like 30
of nobel prize winners in physics at one
point we're jewish people you know we
make up uh i'm not a jewish egotist i
mean all you have to do is
is get in front of a one of my fellow uh
tribal members at uh you know
at a certain event and and you'll you'll
realize that they're just human beings
like everybody else but
but i said avi do you think human nature
has changed in other words if
tomorrow you know stephen meyer's book
gets a blurb from god
and it says this book is uh you know and
this is my favorite book of all time
this is how i did it a day later
yeah right do you think a day later well
that's like o.j simpson's book yeah
if i did it uh but do you think a day
later anyone would still believe it or a
week later no we'd come up with
different explanations i remember
hearing in the soviet union
in the 1980s you know was very very um
anti-religious and there was you know
there were there were people in
and that would work for the you know in
the physics departments etc
uh who would say things like you know
the the splitting of the red sea was
just caused by a huge wind storm
and uh and there was a gravitational
pull because there was an eclipse back
then
and i actually had richard friedman
who's a dear friend a dear friend of
mine he writes about yeah
but is that any better is that any
better or worse than a miracle i mean
so to me it's kind of well in a way
that's what that would be a miracle
i mean that would be how god would do it
how would god
actually perform the miracle of
splitting the red sea well he would
generate up a super storm with strong
winds and he would have an earthquake or
whatever
and and this one i'm getting at is is
this question of well how does god do it
how does the mind interact with the
stuff
you know how does it reach into the
universe from wherever god is
and stir the particles in some way to
cause the miracle or
laws of nature or whatever uh i had just
had on
the podcast to um philosophers james
davidson
davis and hunter and paul nedelliski
they wrote this book called
science and the good it's a critique of
uh myself sam harris d pinker and and
jonathan height and
others that are kind of doing
evolutionary ethics
and they the the entire book is
basically a critique saying this is why
these guys have not explained the
origins of morality much less
how to derive an art from an is okay so
i reviewed the book and i liked the book
and
then i thought i'll just have them on
the podcast so i did we're going to
release that in a couple weeks i think
any case turns out they're theist
philosophers both of them i had no idea
so to their credit they wrote this book
without ever once mentioning god or
anything like that or even their
positions
so we spent most of the time talking
about why evolutionary
psychologists and ethicists are wrong so
i said okay
then how do you think it happened what
do you think is the origins of morality
and in in so many words it was you know
god did it it's like yeah
i know but how i mean in other words the
you know it's kind of a god of the gaps
argument
and even though modern intelligent
designers disclaimed that
they said we're not doing filling in the
god of the gaps well you are you're just
saying
in so many fancy words god did it well
but
how and then if it turns out you know
they have some argument well he used
the storm to cause the sea to splitter
or or he caused the
quantum foam fluctuation that's how he
created the universe
how is that any different from what
scientists are trying to do to figure
out how it happened
right and that's the one of the problems
i actually have with people like neil
degrasse tyson and michio kaku again
guess on my show and so i say it with
respect sean carroll made this argument
to me in
in person a long time ago that you know
isaac newton knew that there were these
gaps
in the principia in the in the theory of
universal gravitation rather
and that um the only way he could plug
them uh the instability because
gravitation is only the only force
that's only attractive it has no
repulsive gravity
in the particle to particle sense the
way that electronic charges do
etcetera nuclear forces can have
repulsive forces um and so
he plugged it that hole by postulating
that god or angels kept the particles in
place
at certain times in their orbit when
their so-called gravitational resonances
and uh and stephen meyer to his credit
did the research he was at cambridge
after all
and he looked through the prince there's
no there's not once does newton make
that argument
and so you have to be careful with the
god of the gaps on the other side i feel
like
you know for for the um secular
community
to have more uh intellectual honesty
than
than the theist community they have to
have higher intellectual standards
and to me to let that slip and stevens
documented this particular
um like that's a huge that's a huge
lacuna in
in there in their case as far as i'm
concerned because i actually believe
that for a very long time and i re you
can read it in
kaku's book he talks about it also kaka
talks about the
um the famous questions of thomas
aquinas and and you know those better
than anybody but one of those is like
anything designed had a designer and
michio's just kind of glibly
he says one of those is a good question
you know where the universe come from
but then he says
oh well like evolution explains the
origin of life
and i'm like actually have you read
darwin's letter to huxley you know
like where he says it's as it's as much
rubbish
to think of the origin of life as it is
the origin of matter
and it's like no the origin of species
is what darwin was talking about not the
origin of life
those are hugely different things and
michio just says oh no evolution
explains life no there's not a single
working
experimentalist in in the field of
origin of life research
um which is going on around the world
that has ever been able to replicate
even though it's not simple versions of
it so there's a huge
i'd say disadvantage to trying to take
on the myers of the world
uh there's many many obstacles rather
there's one huge obstacle to accepting
god which is just like the
implausibility
you know and the in the and the
hiddenness of such an entity if he
does exist but but the other you know i
feel like theists have
our atheists have it really hard because
we don't understand the origin of life
we're not any closer than we were a
hundred years ago you know people talk
about the miller urey experiment
that was done in part here i mean uh
yuri and milner were both here in san
diego
yeah um well robert hazen has a nice
course
at the teaching company i think it's
like 24 lectures on the
history of the origins of life research
there's actually you know a dozen
different theories
back to the consensus problem you know
there's no consensus
there's not there's not an emptiness of
or a lack of
theories about how it happened including
uh
directed panspermia or just panspermia
in general without
the direction um but but there's no
consensus so okay
maybe it's a super hard problem maybe
they're just not asking the question the
right way
or whatever you know but again we you
know what's the alternative
well you know god just did it well how
you know did he use rna to create dna
because if that's how it happened then
we should continue with that research
or did he use on some other planet to
use some other self-replicating
molecules that weren't either rna or dna
okay that would be interesting
you know but but but what exactly did
did the deity do or whatever
anyway so a more a more broad question
since you used the word agnostic to
describe yourself you know this word was
coined by
thomas henry huxley in 1869 by which he
meant
not knowable in any kind of empirical or
rational sense there's no experiment
you're going to run there's no set of
clever arguments like the cosmological
argument or whatever that everybody's
going to go oh
yeah that's right it's just not knowable
so
i mean today most people use the word to
mean like well i'm agnostic about
climate change you know maybe some new
data will come in and then i'll make up
my mind and decide if
if i believe or if i'm still skeptical
no the
so one position i'm conflicted about
this i tend to think
we're never going to know right it's
just we've all hit this epistemological
wall maybe it's an ontological wall
maybe we can never know
it may be an unknowable concept or maybe
i'm wrong maybe
the the kind of universe we have is the
kind of universe that
that would imply there's a god if you
follow stephen meyer's arguments
or to follow victor stenger's arguments
in his book god the failed hypothesis he
says no actually
god is a testable hypothesis and he
failed to test and here's the ten
reasons why
you know and so um i'm just curious what
you think about that
is this an unknowable concept is that
what you mean by agnostic or are you
do you mean i'm waiting for more
evidence to come in or better arguments
i so i kind of got this from freeman
dyson who called himself an agnostic but
again
he was functionally indistinguishable
from richard dawkins i used to tease him
i regret teasing him
you know because he's such a sweet man
uh but anyway we had a great uh kind of
uh friendship uh that uh i i think about
to miss him all the time
but one thing he said to me is you know
he said brian there are um
two different things in science or in
life he said there are mysteries and
there are puzzles
like a puzzle my kids can do a rubik's
cube i can never do a rubik's cube
without like taking apart you know and
reassembling it
actually i could do it i joke if you put
if you gave me a rubik's cube that was
solved on five sides
i could get that six side no questions
asked but um but that was a puzzle
meaning it was something that somebody
smarter than me
if not me could do and solve a mystery
is something maybe no one can ever solve
and is unsoluble
and insoluble given what we have as
human beings but that wasn't a problem
that wasn't a reason for despair
according to him and it isn't for me
because we all you know there is a part
of life
even if you're religious that you have
to make up meaning whether that meaning
that you make up for yourself
is based on you know what you want to
have happen to you in the afterlife or
what legacy you want to have leave to
your kids
what i find so delicious about life is
in practice so i get to practice
not just physics but experimental
physics i get to build telescopes i get
to go and search and cool and
interesting places
i get to interact with smart people from
around the world and
and think for a living and convert food
into brain into uh you know into writing
into words that someone else
maybe 20 years from now will encounter
um so for me that's the mystery aspect
of it there's no proof that any one of
us
is going to ever get the answer and get
you know solve it
for example it's not for a lack of
trying i don't feel very convinced by
you know kind of the militant atheism
and so i gravitate towards a practicing
agnostic
the emphasis is on practice so for me i
go to temple
for me i study aramaic and i taught
myself hebrew at age 30.
you know i was an altar boy in the
catholic church both my parents were
born jewish biologically i was jewish
from birth just the same way that you
know i would say we were jewish in the
same way the panda express is
like authentic chinese food you know
it's just like cultural like we'd have
uh yeah we'd go to synagogue we used to
joke you know two days a year
on christmas and easter but then when my
mom you know remarried and she got
married to an irish catholic man
eating i began i fell in love with the
catholic church
and i became an altar boy michael this
jewish boy at
age 13 when i should have been having my
bar mitzvah i never had a bar mitzvah
instead i had a i was confirmed baptized
and i was an altar boy
until i learned from father monsignor
robert skelty
in chappaqua new york i learned that you
had to be celibate and at age 13
that wasn't something i was super
interested in i don't know why
but what was the appeal what was the
appeal of catholicism at that time to
you
i i thought it was off uh it's
authenticity it's
seriousness it's lack of kind of
frivolity
i didn't see people going up there with
like you know sandals and flip-flops and
people laughed it's a
very warm religion it's very loving and
open
there's emphasis on food and drink you
know it's like they're forbidden
to have a sexual relation so they they
kind of
malleable you know in terms of drinking
and smoking cigars or pipes
anyway it seemed very it seemed very
interesting to me and it was part of an
elite
and i love that aspect of catholicism
until i learned about
this guy galileo and how he was
mistreated by the catholic church
and even by the 1980s when i was an
altar boy
he hadn't been pardoned he actually has
never been formally pardoned
the vatican did admit that they were
wrong uh by the way they were it wasn't
like something like the pope
was some expert scientist they have
scientists to this day michael the
vatican observatory is one of the best
telescopic observatories on earth and
there were a lot of things i liked about
the catholic church's
science in that um lemaitre didn't want
to claim
evidence for the big bang based on his
big bang model that he ushered in but
that's moving aside from the point so
then i became an atheist
i believe anything that did any harm to
a brilliant intellectual like galileo
was not for me
and as i talked about in losing no prize
i thought
well christianity is kind of judaism 2.0
and by modus tollens i can refute the
conclusion that the antecedent must be
refuted
and therefore i don't need to study
judaism and their things stood
you know until uh until september 11
2001
when i realized i knew almost nothing
about the religion of my birth
and for some reason this religion played
a big role
in the evolution of our universe and its
current state so
i decided then and there i wanted to
learn more about judaism i wanted to
have a jewish family
and to learn and and that required i
learned hebrew which is really hard at
age 30.
what's 9 11 got to do with that because
of their
um hatred of jews and anti-semitism and
anti-israel
it was more it was more like how is
israel why is this tiny little country
that i previously had no affiliation for
why was it in the center
of of all these events going on at the
center of
of the g of the western world and how
what role did it play in america's
founding for example
and what role did it play in the current
political dynamic
of you know of that war the second gulf
war that then
was uh becoming and it just made me feel
like an ignoramus because i knew nothing
about judaism like
it's one thing to be like to not be
jewish and look i don't know much about
islam or
or um you know being a you know
mormonism
but i do know about you know a little
more about catholicism at that point
than i did i knew a lot of the arguments
for atheism i had read a lot of uh the
earlier work
um and so but for me it's it comes down
to practice so as an agnostic who
practices
not that i know that you know it's
unknowable or
but if you desist from the quest like
when you're out mountain biking or road
biking
you know like i bet sometimes you don't
really feel like going out on your bike
michael
but you do it anyway because it's part
of who you are and it influenced your
your entire character yeah so for me
it's had a wonderful influence
michael you know like once a week to
have a day off where i don't send you an
email
i'm not gonna do it be on twitter i know
you made fun of me because i took so
long to get this article done you're
like get off twitter i'm like i'm off
it's
25 hours a week but it's it's it is
refreshing
it is restorative and so i said you know
there's an accumulation of evidence that
at least the
activity of this life is beneficial to
me
and then at worst in kind of pascal's
wager what's the worst that can happen i
laid this
life true to this religion maybe i never
come to
you know the firm belief that my rabbi
has in the existence of god
but if i desist from trying i know i'll
never believe it like like richard
always says
there's no such thing as a christian
child like he says he basically has
called it like child abuse to say like
your child
or zuckerman has said this like no one's
born into a religion like no one's born
believe
but i know something you know from
experience that that actually it's
extremely difficult
to be born to atheist parents and to
become religious
it's just it's just that's just a truth
like i think it's because of the way
that atheism
is sort of almost in opposition to an
existing paradigm
uh that the practitioners name of the
parents will
really make it almost like a forbidden
thing for their kids not not like
literally
but the kids will get this perception
that this isn't something for me
and i didn't want my kids to go through
that and so i you know i've left it open
and
and they're learning and i'm learning
and and it's continuing that as a
lifestyle
and who knows what will happen along the
way yeah i think here you're touching on
the
you know social and psychological
benefits of religion that really have
nothing to do
with intelligent design theory or
quantum physics or
or any of the stuff we're talking about
which you know you and i
love these conversations but the average
person going to church or
synagogue or whatever religious
service they go to they're not going
there to hear some arguments for the
fine-tuning
or the first cause the prime mover or
the kalam cosmological argument they're
going there for the
the camaraderie and the social aspects
the food free parking
you know the you know the kind of kind
of moral uplifting stories that much of
the
biblical stories uh could convey
so i mean one of the things points i
always make about
mythic truths versus empirical truths is
that
for example if you're arguing well the
you know the miracle of the party of the
red sea
you know the actual natural explanation
for that is this wind storm or the
earthquake or whatever
um you know i think if that's the route
you're taking you're kind of missing the
point of the story
you know the analogy i make is like well
were there really
four brothers karamazov uh
in russia in 19th century and it's like
that
you know dostoevsky just made this up
but it's not completely made up there's
a
kind of a a literary or mythic truth in
the story
about human nature about human culture
human history
and and uh you know the tensions that
happen when
when a you know kind of a backwards
nation like
uh russia becomes modern and goes
through the state you know that's
you know it'd be it'd be like you know
jk rowling holding a press conference
and saying you know this whole harry
potter thing you know
it's actually true i didn't make it up
you know there really is this place and
you know the nine and a half at the
train station and there's this guy named
vulture
no i mean this would be absurd you know
we people would rightly think she'd lost
her mind
um but but to even talk about that is to
miss the point of the story
right so i often think right uh my me
and my fellow atheists
including the things we've published in
in the magazine
we published back in the 90s an article
that jesus this is before dan brown
uh it became popular that jesus was
never really dead on the cross he was
kind of slipped into a coma
and they gave him this substance that
put him in a three-day uh
coma and so he's now in this cold
tomb that kind of preserved the body for
a couple of days and he wakes up
and then he and mary whisk off to well
the theory was india at the time i think
dan brown sent him off to france to have
children and so on
but as interesting as those are you know
i think you've kind of missed the point
of the resurrection
story you know it has nothing to do with
you know did he really
raise from the dead after three days and
so on i mean a lot of christians
absolutely think that that has to be
empirically true
or else why bother being a christian he
could just be a jews say because jews
they accept that there is going to be a
messiah he just hasn't come yet because
the story of jesus is not what the old
testament predicts that well this is
what you say
uh that you know that would happen and
that's not who jesus was
okay fine but again you know there's a
there's a deeper point to the story
about you know
redemption starting over you know the
oppression of the jews by the romans
and this is a common theme throughout
history is that oppressed peoples tend
to
uh have mythic stories about a savior
coming and you know
like the the native american ghost dance
that i like to tell you know in 1890 the
closing of the american west
the us government is oppressing these
native americans putting them on
reservations and so on
and all of a sudden this thing erupts
you know the dakota sioux have this
ghost dance in which they're all
chanting for days on end
about how you know the buffalo are going
to return and the white man's going to
leave
and and they have these vests that they
would wear that they believed would be
impervious to
a white man's bullets and on and on it's
it's very much
i mean this guy will voca he was very
much a jesus-like messiah
figure and you know and i in my one of
my books i have you know
half a dozen examples of this throughout
history were oppressed people
you know so that's what to me the story
has much deeper meaning
to which someone like you know my fellow
atheists would say well it's just not
true so it's a bunch of [ __ ] we
don't have to even think about it well
you know that's too simple
you know kind of a interpretation of
these things it is
i mean one of my favorite things you
know jefferson had a bible where he
removed all the miracles and
i'm working on my magnum opus will be a
bible with
no violations of the laws of physics and
actually going through it there aren't
that there aren't
there aren't that many violations of
laws of physics and in fact
there are very interesting kind of
either they're jokes michael or
like you know kind of uh insider you
know kind of uh
humor where you have things like the sun
is created on the fourth day
so it obviously can't be that they meant
day
now the question is you know what did it
really mean and you know and how do we
interpret it
but i i think they're they're you know
again i've said this in in talks i've
given
you know looking at the bible and
expecting it to have anything to say
about not just noma or anything like
that but expecting
anything to say about physics or
cosmology or biology and
heritability is like looking at you know
a transcript
of of the you know 2008 housing crisis
uh you know you know kind of autopsy of
forensic report
and then saying oh this is this is
really going to tell me how to you know
raise
labrador retriever like it has nothing
maybe the word labrador appears in there
once but i make the point you know
and at one point i said um there's
there's about 35 verses
in genesis 1 1 about you know through
chapter two or three
about maybe the big bang or the origin
of species you know whatever
and then there's 35 000 total uh verses
in the old testament which is all i
really know and uh so that's point one
percent
so it's one of a thousand so imagine you
pick up a book and it's a thousand pages
long
and it says on the cover it says great
you know basketball heroes
uh on it and then like there's 99 999
pages of the
of the six you know really outstanding
jewish basketball players that have been
in nba history and then there's one
about
lebron james and michael jordan and you
know that's funny and by the way one of
them was a good
convert i think statement anyway the
point being
this is not a book about that and nor is
a brief history of time a book about how
i want to raise my kids
so and not that i raised my kids
according to the bible but there are
very interesting things
about the torah that you know would be
great you know part
for three someday to talk about not the
science of the torah i
i really find those kinds of things you
know ridiculous because it's it's
clear it's not again the sun is created
on the fourth day
and it doesn't take an apologist to say
it obviously doesn't mean what we think
it means
but by the way i have to tell that to my
religiously inclined you know uh
jewish friends will say this is proof
you know that god can do a miracle you
know that he created it before the sun
and the sun is
that had a very specific purpose it was
it had to speak to readers 3000 years
ago or whenever it was compiled and
written
and how to speak to readers today and i
always joke you know i kill for one
percent of god's book sales and
that's serious because you know this
thing has been relevant a lot longer
than a brief history of time
brief history of time i hope it's out of
date i hope my losing the nobel prize is
no
not read in a hundred years because we
know so much more about at least the
physics
but um you know i've often thought you
know it would be a bad thing
if if science doesn't get overturned but
how much more so is it good that
things like the the the torah and the
talmud which is the second holiest work
they've endured for thousands of years
there's a reason for it and it's not
just mass delusions of crowds
there is wisdom and but that's not to
say it comes up as easily as
even string theory comes to certain
people yeah
brian we've been going over an hour and
a half let me just switch to the
lightning round here and ask just a
couple quick questions
back to your your article forested
skeptic let's see if we can keep these
short what is gravity
ah so gravity is yeah gravity is uh
is the weakest of all the forces it's
it's some sun sense the most
uh mysterious not only because it
refuses to be
wedded to the other forces and some kind
of theory of everything
should such a thing ever exist but it's
also it hides what it does in
inscrutable places
so gravity is responsible for the large
scale features of the universe but also
the small scale
structure of the structure of the earth
the size of animals
is related to the strength of gravity
it's the porous understood the constant
that governs gravitational interactions
irrespective of it not being found a
theory of everything
we understand the gravitational constant
of newton's
law capital g that's the poorest known
of all the so-called fundamental
constants of nature it's very hard to
measure it on small scales
it's even harder to measure it at the
earliest times
and it may be impossible michael to
measure it
in the situations where it is most
interesting and relevant i.e
at the center of a black hole it's
called a singularity or perhaps at the
beginning of time
you know which which is a moment
preceded by no other moments
because those are firewalled off by the
expansion of the universe in one case in
the big bang uh singularity
and by the so-called event horizon in
the
context of the uh black hole singularity
so it may be that singularities don't
actually exist but we'll never know
because they're both completely
inscrutable okay let me ask you let me
ask you this question
when i drop this object uh it's not
being pulled to the earth by a force
it's what push by space-time i think is
how michio described it
and even that intuitively doesn't feel
quite right or
yeah i heard that description it's an
interesting description so
what happens is gravity warps the paths
of
of uh trajectories such that if
the object will fall with what we
perceive as a
as a um as a curvature or sorry as
it will take the shortest amount of time
and it will uh behave as if it's being
accelerated
but there's no actual reason that the
gravitational force that pulls on the
phone when you drop it
uh should be mediated by the same term
this charge that we call
mass there's no reason that mass should
be the same as to push an object
the fact that they are exact agreement
to 12 decimal places
is one of the greatest mysteries of all
time and is one of the ones that galileo
first perceived when he apocryphally
maybe dropped the cannonball and uh
and a ball of wood off of the leaning
tower of pisa and we're still learning
things about about gravity every day
it's the most mysterious of all the
forces and maybe we'll never be able to
unify it there's no law that says we
will
what is time or space time if you prefer
um i only can say what time does
so time is intimately connected to
change
in fact that is maybe the most basic law
of all of physics is that
change happens and that change is
what clocks can measure so our bodies
are clocks we have psychological time
but i actually mean
the physical degradation of our cells is
a type of a clock
uh there are clops celestial events that
that occur
these are things that clocks can measure
and so time
and it's almost tautological you can
almost not separate
the behavior of what we call time from
the existence of clocks
and so it's no surprise that actually
the first measurements of gravity by
people like
galileo came about at a time when the
first clocks were kind of coming
together
and so for that reason it's almost
impossible to answer the question of
time without referring to entropy
and entropy being the rate the tendency
of syste of objects within a closed
system
to um to get more and more disordered uh
uh
um from state function you know state
description to state description
so if we don't have a great description
if my the cellular
disintegration due to entropy is
happening at a certain
rate as a clock why does it slow down if
i'm
at a high speed if i'm moving at a high
speed compared to somebody who's just
stationary
yeah so that that occurs because of what
is called time dilation
which is a which is a distinction that
you think of as puzzling
because we don't have experience with
things operating at the speed of light
so the notion of if you're sitting on a
train
and the train pulls away next next door
to your train
it feels like you're moving even though
it's really the other train moving
that's a consequence of those of
what's called galilean relativity which
behaves uh
governs the behavior of things in motion
at low speeds galilean relativity is the
extreme
limit and the low speed limit of
einstein's special relativity
so the theory of special relativity
incorporates two changes that take place
lengths get smaller uh and and time gets
bigger
so you can close a barn door on an
object that's
nominally bigger than the separation
between the barn door and its wall
if this object is moving fast enough
relative to the barn which is stationary
but also things like muons which have
been in the news lately
they will live longer that uh if they're
in motion in the cosmos at high
velocities accelerated by a supernova
explosion perhaps
than they will on earth it's stationary
in the laboratory that's called time
dilation
so but the total interval so in other
words that kind of the sum
of time uh the effects of time that time
gets uh
lengthened um and and distances get
contracted
they're conserved in other words the
product of the time
uh times the lengthening of time uh the
speed of light times the lengthening of
time
and then the shortening of length that
you add those up you get the same amount
and that's deeply related to the
conservation of energy
so so that phenomenon that you are
witnessing is a byproduct of
things in high velocity and the
conservation of energy
are most closely held of all physical
lines
okay what is nothing in this sense
uh let me let's just ask it in the
deepest possible way you know you have a
box there's nothing in it
uh so you take the universe you take all
the stars and planets and people
and all the atoms and so on but they're
still
ideas or logic or math or the laws of
nature whatever those are
so you have to take those out and there
can't even be any sentience asking the
question
and and there can't even be nothing
because nothing is a concept for the
not to exist at some point i don't even
know what i'm talking about
well i think about so of course that's
impossible to answer but i will say
something
you can get all the integers if you
start with nothing
i don't know if you've ever gone through
this it's called set theory now there's
a wonderful book called naive set theory
it was my late father's favorite book by
i think paul halmosh
with an umlaut in there somewhere that
your wife will appreciate
and um and and the way you do it is kind
of interesting because a lot of cultures
um you know think of god as one and then
you know kind of everything else is
emptiness so it's really a foundation
the universe is kind of binary and i'm
not going to get will you know i'm not
like that but the universe is kind of
binary in that you can get one
starting from zero and the way you do it
is this michael
how many sets of zero bananas are there
the one i don't know
there's one set right yeah okay so and
then um what does the set of
zero bananas and and conceive of no
apples or a universe with nothing in it
how many
empty sets are there there's only one
set that contains no elements
okay all right and so therefore starting
with nothing you get one
okay and then starting with one and one
you can get two and yeah
all right you can get all the integers
at least that way all the rational
numbers that way
interesting yeah so could you get a
universe from nothing
uh in here you guys start talking about
like quantum foam
and the fluctuations and the colliding
brains and
again i you know i get lost pretty quick
so those are the those are the mysteries
right so they
they they confuse us because they
present as puzzles but they're probably
mystery
yeah yeah well brian this is an
unbelievably fascinating quest uh
conversation because
we've dealt with pretty much all the big
topics did we leave anything out
i think i know we went way beyond your
cover story which i really appreciate
all right there's your next book you
have to put all this together and
respond
to all the uh intelligent designers and
everybody else
on the spectrum as it were i know
i i i can equal opportunity offender but
what is your next big project what are
you working on
what are you working on i'm working on
the first
audio book uh translation uh or not
translation recording
yeah with uh yeah with carlo rivelli
and then i'm working on another book
called think like a nobel prize winner
i've interviewed nine nobel prize
winners and counting on my podcast into
the impossible
on youtube dr brian keating and i'm
working on
that book and then i'm also maybe
thinking of writing a book
about the things we leave behind and
what are known as ethical wills
what we want to be remembered by us not
monetarily etc but but in terms of what
impact we made on other humans through
our wisdom that we've acquired
and uh that those are kind of
interesting
like the environment
yeah the environment but more like what
wisdom and i actually asked this of
andrewian
wife widow of carl sagan among many
other people on my podcast i always ask
them
uh i haven't i didn't ask you because i
started asking these questions after you
came on my pocket you gave me my start
in podcasting
exactly a year ago and so it was before
i developed these patented questions
that i now close each and every episode
with
um and so when you're on my show next
i'm going to ask you these questions but
one of them is what would you put in
your ethical will
and another one is how did you go into
the impossible which is arthur c
clarke's famous line the only way of
knowing what's possible is to go beyond
the limits into the impossible
so yeah i'm working on a whole bunch of
different projects but really the
simon's observatory building this
telescope in chile
with 300 of my closest uh and best and
brightest
scientist in the world that's going to
keep me busy for the next few years oh
that's your
teacher to deliver your scientific
project is that the chile
i didn't know you were working on that
oh that's my main project what what is
the hope that it will
that it will detect or discover or see
yeah so we don't talk about what we want
to discover else we get uh we get
diluted by nobel prizes and such but
what we are designed to look for are the
imprints of early
gravitational waves in the infant
universe if they exist
as i talk about in the skeptic article
those would be perhaps the only
harbinger the only impromptu of
inflation
which comes along concomitantly with the
multiverse
and then but also for clusters of
galaxies for the imprint michael we
don't know
where magnetism comes in uh comes to the
universe we don't know how it originated
so we talk about these highfalutin laws
of gravity and
and string theory we don't know where
the earliest magnetic field
in the universe came from we don't know
what caused it
and that's one of the things we're
designed to detect and then the last
thing is
that we're dis that i'm hoping to look
for not to discover
necessarily but it would be more
startling to me michael
than discovering inflationary
gravitational waves
and that's called lorentz lorenz
violation
so lorentz violation is lorenz
invariance is the symmetry is the
founding principle of physics
it basically means that i don't care if
i do this experiment dropping my phone
here in san diego or in santa barbara it
doesn't make a bit of difference
it's independence of location it's
independence of time you could do it in
1600 or you could do it today it will
behave the same way
what if it doesn't we actually can't
test things over very big distances here
on earth at
very long times on earth but we can with
the cosmos and so that's what i'm
looking for we're looking for departures
from the basic underpinnings of all of
modern physics namely lorenzen variants
and if we find that to me that would be
more interesting than discovering the
origin of the universe via
these gravitational waves yeah that's
fascinating that's lyell's principle of
uniformitarianism the
past is the key to the present maybe
it's not maybe the speed of light was
different
right in the past or gravity was
different or whatever
right that reminds me the last thing
i'll say about that hockinghawking book
there's a scene in there where hawking
had a party
um and and cambridge in the i think it
was in the uh
maybe the early 2000s or maybe maybe not
even that long ago
and then the next day he advertised the
party and he said come
to cambridge at this time and he said
and at the party he said welcome time
traveler
and so yeah all these things are very
very interesting you know can we
discover that the laws that we already
know that certain properties of physics
depend on whether you're looking at them
in a mirror or not which is very bizarre
in other words if i look at this
uh leatherman you know multi-tool
falling down it doesn't matter you're
actually seeing the mirror image of it
doesn't
you can't tell that that's happening but
there's certain phenomena called in the
weak interaction that violate this this
uh symmetry property called charge
parity
i wonder and my colleagues and i wonder
if the universe
has kind of a handedness to it if it has
a preferred direction
in space and time that actually we we
assume it doesn't
only because we only have such limited
distances here on earth
and limited time scales in the human
life but through looking as far back in
the universe as we can with these
powerful telescopes
we hope to reveal that symmetries have
to be broken that's where interesting
things happen you have
i don't know do you ever see this thing
michael where they show a picture of
brad pitt who besides you know you and
me
was was considered the handsomest man uh
on earth by people magazine
um skeptic magazine had a different
different enhancement but then they take
his picture
and they just split them down the middle
yeah and they just reflect once
and he's grotesque he's horrible he's
disgusting even i'm better looking than
him
and uh so symmetry is when they're so
that means that broken symmetries are
more attractive and appealing
so we're looking for those broken
symmetries so far we haven't seen it it
means that nature is
startlingly resilient and impervious to
all of our testing but that just makes
it more of a mystery to
hopefully turn into a puzzle that's why
it would be interesting to come back a
thousand years from now or
or be chronically frozen and woken up
and then go oh
that's the explanation for that that was
so obvious why didn't we see it in the
21st century
well all right brian thank you so much
for coming on i really appreciate it
great conversation i'm gonna
if you like this video please let me
know what you thought in the comments
you